[Music]
[Applause]
will the audience please rise for the
singing of one verse of the national
anthem
[Music]
dr. gray I have here the charter of MIT
Paul Edward gray by the authority of the
corporation and with the enthusiastic
approval of the faculty the alumni and
the student body and this distinguished
assembly I present into your keeping the
charter of the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology and invest you with all of
the authority privileges and
responsibilities of the office of
President may you serve the Institute
and dignify its office of president with
all the skill wisdom and dedication
which our confidence Accords to you and
may your administration be memorable
mr. Johnson I accept this charter as the
symbol of the office of president of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology I
do so with a full sense of a magnitude
of my responsibility I'm deeply deeply
grateful for the trust it represents and
I pledge myself to work unremittingly
with the corporation the faculty and
staff our students and our alumni for
the greatest good of this institution
[Applause]
I join with my colleagues to extend the
personal welcome to all of you here in
Killian Court fellow members of the MIT
community students faculty and staff
members of the corporation and alumni
and we welcome especially for this
joyful occasion our friends our
neighbors and visitors from sister
institutions in the Academy in industry
and in public service Priscilla and I
hope that it will be possible to greet
each of you personally before this day
ends
I've been asked frequently this morning
how it feels to come to this occasion
and I guess I feel like that man who
worked for Ringling Brothers Barnum and
Bailey who was known as the human
cannonball for two days ago on Wednesday
professor Kenneth Hoffman chairman a the
chairman of the inaugural committee
fired the cannon and I am now in
ballistic free flight somewhere near the
apogee as you know there is not much one
can do to influence the trajectory at
that point but I have faith and
confidence that out there there are
people with a big net I come to this
lectern imbued with many and varied
emotions and feelings this position is
for me the culmination of a lifetime of
intimate association with this
extraordinary institution as student
alumnus member of the faculty and
administrator most of my adult life has
centered on the surroundings
of this magnificent courtyard I stand
here today as no stranger to you and the
Institute is a central part of my life
the dominant emotions I feel are those
of profound respect than humility for
this place expects and deserves uncommon
performance from those who are
privileged to serve it with me on this
platform today are the four men who have
served as president of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology during the 30
years of my life here Jim Killian Jay
Stratton Howard Johnson and Jerry
Wiesner I owe much to each of them
because of their legacies of devoted
stewardship and because of the support
and the encouragement they have given me
they have provided continuity and wisdom
through many MIT generations years which
have seen enormous changes in the nature
of Science and Technology as well as in
the character of the Institute I'm
particularly indebted to Jerry Wiesner
with whom I've worked so closely during
the years since he became president in
1971 his generous sharing of the
accomplishments and the problems of his
presidency has provided me with an
extraordinary apprenticeship words fail
Jerry to express my indebtedness to you
my purpose in these remarks is to
express my sense of the mission of MIT
particularly as we look to the
challenges and the opportunities of the
1980s as MIT enters in you decade it
takes its place in a world whose
prospects for peace and justice are
uncertain a world in which economic
security literacy and health are not
enjoyed by most people with all our
progress poverty is still the only
prospect and hunger a condition of life
for a shockingly large portion of the
world's people even in the most advanced
countries such as our own driving
inflation and painful levels of
unemployment strain the society and cast
shadows on our dreams here in the United
States in the midst of a presidential
election year there is a widely shared
sense that many of the old values and
old ways are not appropriate somehow to
these times and yet the political
process has not produced new paradigms
for addressing the problems of our age
some suggest that the political process
itself including the structure and
organization of our government is unable
to respond effectively to the complexity
of our world and to the shrinking scales
of time and distance earlier in this
century people look to science and
technology to light the path of progress
this is no longer the case that early
and somewhat naive optimism has been
replaced by a skepticism and by an
alarming decline in scientific literacy
in this
country this decline reflects in part
the difficulty of keeping up with fields
which grow and change with astonishing
speed but there is also amongst the
public and ignorance weariness and
discomfort about most things scientific
and technological such an attitude must
be of great concern to us here for we
have an essential responsibility to make
the case for science and technology in
the service of humankind MIT is and
should be expected to provide leadership
for improving the level of scientific
literacy and for nurturing talent in and
for today's world probably the toughest
questions we face today have to do with
the social and political context of the
decade ahead
I venture no political or economic
predictions my ability to divine the
future complexion of our society and of
our economy is no better than yours
there are no easy answers and there may
be no short path to finding any answers
there is one certainty however the young
men and women who entered the Institute
as freshmen three weeks ago are the
future and our hope for a better world
rests just as surely with them and with
what they learn here as it does with the
discoveries and advances in knowledge to
which our faculty contribute our
challenge as we chart our future course
is to set our priorities and to forge
educational and research programs that
will bring that hope closer to reality
meeting this challenge requires I
believe that we both preserve and
transform MIT we must preserve its
historic intellectual focus and its
insistence on excellence and at the same
time we must transform its programs to
serve the needs of the future I would
like to speak first of the special
character and distinctive purpose we
must preserve as our touchstone for the
future we are a science-based University
which places special emphasis on
education we must preserve our
unswerving commitment to the quality and
vigor of our core activities and
engineering and science we must do so in
ways that respect the integrity of basic
science in ways that uphold the values
of applied science and technology and in
ways that reflect and engage the social
context in which science and technology
occur we must preserve and continue to
build strong programs in the humanities
the arts and the social sciences these
dimensions of intellectual and creative
experience are necessary to the
definition of MIT as a university
devoted to the broad reach of human
history and human inquiry and they are
essential to our providing a full and
balanced education for our students we
must preserve our emphasis on education
we have a responsibility to educate our
students for civilised leadership as
professionals and citizens of the world
our responsibility to them and to the
generations that will follow
is to support them in the development of
their intellectual powers to help them
shape their values and attitudes toward
increased caring and compassion and to
encourage their personal growth as
creative sovereign human beings the
emphasis on education however cannot be
sustained without the research strength
of the Institute our efforts to push out
the frontiers of knowledge to seek
answers to the basic questions are
fundamental to the life of this
institution research at MIT inspires
nourishes and helps to organize all that
occurs in this academic community it
provides the basis for graduate and
postgraduate education and contributes
in powerful ways to the development of
the creative abilities of our
undergraduates the active involvement of
students particularly undergraduate
students in research adds fresh
perspective to the research enterprise
and it reminds us once again of the
curiosity the enthusiasm and the stamina
which provide the spark for innovation
and achievement we must therefore
preserve research and education as
complementary activities on this campus
indeed I would say that the blending of
research and education defines MIT and
our future must continue to rely on
their combined strengths I believe
therefore that in contemplating any new
research opportunity or program we must
ask each time how will it contribute to
our capacity as an educational
institution what benefits our
opportunities will it bring to future
generations of students
and in turn we must ask how will new
educational programs challenge the
imagination of the faculty the men and
women on whom we rely for institutional
growth and renewal I would now like to
discuss some ways in which we must
transform MIT there are I believe three
related challenges which we must meet if
MIT is to sustain its leadership and
influence in the decade of the 1980s and
beyond in setting these challenges
before you I am NOT suggesting the
change at MIT should be precipitous but
I do believe that we can together take
the bull' steps necessary to secure the
Institute's future first we must
rededicate science and technology as
socially powerful activities we continue
to hear the complaint that the world has
had too much of science and technology
that many of our human and social ills
are the direct result of unanticipated
and deleterious artifacts of technology
for stood upon the world by technicians
with tunnel vision it is clear however
that the future development not only of
this nation but of the world is
inexorably tied to continued scientific
progress and to the humane and
thoughtful applications of science what
is needed is not a retreat from science
and technology but a more complete
Science and Technology we must strive to
develop among ourselves among our
students and in the public at large an
understanding of the fact that
engineering and science are by their
very nature humanistic enterprises
scientific inquiry is at once a most
natural and highly refined expression of
the human mind and spirit it is derived
from native curiosity about the nature
of our world and about the universe and
it results in speculations and concepts
which help to give meaning and order to
that world Engineering and Technology
are both natural and socially derived
enterprises they offer suggestions of
agenda on goals and priorities for
scientific inquiry and as Sir Eric Ashby
noted two decades ago engineering must
engage with the daily process of living
in his remarkable essay entitled
technology and the academics he said a
student who can weave his technology
into the fabric of society can claim to
have a liberal education a student who
cannot weave his technology into the
fabric of society cannot claim even to
be a good technologist although believe
and historical domain of which they are
a part we must continue to be a
sanctuary for the constructive criticism
of the technological enterprise and of
the larger society these principles must
be built into the academic programs of
our students both undergraduate and
graduate and they must be reflected in
the lives and activities of all who
choose to be a part of this institution
the humanities the arts and the social
sciences are essential to our efforts as
distinct intellectual disciplines each
with its own integrity and as forces
which develop a sense of time and place
encourage the arts of expression and
shape the values necessary to the
complete education of our students
indeed a second challenge we face has to
do with education at MIT we should
review the character of the MIT
educational experience paying particular
attention to the questions of pace
coherence and intellectual impact the
young women and men who come to the
Institute as students are highly
motivated able people who are committed
to high levels of achievement and
intellectual effort they join an
environment in which sustained hard work
is the norm and in which sloth is the
cardinal sin
the capacity and passion of our students
for hard work reflect those qualities
exemplified by the MIT faculty this
union between committed hard-working
people and an institution in which hard
work is a deeply ingrained ethos
produces all too often a frenetic pace
of life a pace which is self rewarding
and mutually reinforcing and not without
its costs most undergraduates regularly
register for a remarkable some would say
staggering number of subjects many
faculty undertake heavy burdens of
outside professional commitments which
when superimposed on their
responsibilities to the Institute and
their personal family responsibilities
produce a load which numbs the mind and
the body MIT reinforces these modes of
behavior by rewarding those whose
achievement is exceptional in a group
where exceptional achievement is the
norm now it would be foolhardy for me to
argue particularly in front of this
audience of true believers against the
virtues of hard work rather should we
not ask from time to time about the side
effects of this high-pressure
environment and should we not consider
the possible benefits of more time for
contemplation for a pursuit of interests
and activities outside the professional
realm and for developing friendships in
a sense of community
[Applause]
the pace of MIT contributes I believe to
those centrifugal forces which weaken
our shared central purpose and which
impair the coherence of our educational
programs we must take care that we have
the time and the commitment to educate
the person as well as the future
professional in a specified field if MIT
is to achieve its potential as a
university polarized around science
engineering and the arts to use dr.
Kilian's phrase we must engage in each
new generation in the task of redefining
the meaning of a liberal education based
on science this task is central to our
purpose and to our existence we must
faced it face it head-on if we are to
prepare young people for leadership in
this world for it is in the college
years that students should learn to
examine the basic premises about self
and society to explore different ways of
thinking to develop independent judgment
to sample and relate diverse
intellectual styles and concepts these
explorations form the cornerstone of
later personal and intellectual growth
and they must not be bypassed in the
interest of early specialization our
dedication to providing our students
particularly our undergraduates with a
full and balanced education is a major
unifying force for this institution and
it is a force which would not exist if
we were to concentrate solely on
graduate education on research and on
the advancement of the disciplines the
collective responsibility and commitment
of the faculty to undergraduate
education
is I believe one of our most important
and most valuable assets
[Applause]
it is not easy however for the faculty
to maintain a collective resolve on this
matter the forces which pull us apart
are strong and some have been with us
for a long time
for example the increasing
specialization of knowledge and the
necessary development of strong
disciplinary associations which
transcend individual institutions
inevitably impose limits on one's
concern with internal institutional
issues and with the holistic character
of educational programs now the
increasing complexity and runaway
bureaucracy of the national system of
research support limit the energy any
one person can devote to institutional
issues it is important I believe for us
to resist these forces of estrangement
and to work hard to preserve a sense of
community responsibility for and
participation in the affairs of MIT this
brings me to the third and last
challenge which I set before you today
we should insist that issues centered on
the human condition of the Institute be
at the top of our agenda the
effectiveness the achievements and the
influence of the Institute in the past
have come from people the tens of
thousands of individuals who have cast
their Lots with this place the successes
all the great contributions of this
institution rests on the extraordinary
quality and effectiveness of individuals
who through their love of excellence
their intellectual powers and their
commitment to the first-rate have made
the difference of course it should be
the same in the future and it will be
but it may be more difficult the quality
of life in the academic setting does not
seem as enviable as in the past the
pressures of inflation on salaries the
enticing offers for scientific and
engineering talent in the marketplace
the bureaucratic snares which
characterize many of our relationships
with the government all take their toll
and while we are not alone in this
respect we at MIT may be more vulnerable
than most universities I believe that we
must give special attention to enhancing
those qualities of the Institute which
make it a good and satisfying and
fulfilling place to study and to work I
am particularly concerned that we work
to develop a community of the best
faculty students and staff from as
diverse a population as possible for
over a century MIT has been a place
where exceptional people from all walks
of life come together to work and to
study as such mit has a responsibility
to itself and to the nation to be open
and indeed to reach out to the most
talented and promising people regardless
of race or sex I'm convinced that our
own processes of selection admission and
appointment meet the test of fairness
nevertheless we have not met our own
objectives for making our educational
programs accessible to minorities and to
women or for expanding employment
opportunities for them our
disappointment is evident in enrollments
as well as in our record of employing
women and minorities in professional
capacities we must therefore invent new
ways of reaching those high
gifted people whose capabilities we have
not fully tapped and whose talents we
have not previously nurtured
[Applause]
the patterns of prejudice discrimination
and stereotyping in our society must be
changed and that change requires
leadership from MIT
it is our responsibility to help develop
the full range of talent and potential
in our society our success in meeting
this goal can only be to our benefit as
an institution and as individuals for a
good deal of the learning at MIT occurs
informally and is based on the daily
interactions among people of different
backgrounds experiences and points of
view certainly the International
character of this community has enriched
the Institute over a period of many many
years I believe that the social and
intellectual endowment of MIT will be
similarly enriched by growing numbers of
women and of blacks Hispanics and other
minorities it should be our goal to make
this a welcome environment for them to
attract them in growing numbers to
support their growth and to benefit from
their creativity for the sake of MIT and
for the world we helped to build we
would do well to share the vision of
Margaret Mead articulated nearly 50
years ago but no less relevant today she
said if we are to achieve a richer
culture rich and contrasting values we
must recognize the whole gamut of human
potentialities and so we've a less
arbitrary social fabric one in which
each diverse human gift will find a
fitting place I cherish a vision of a
time and a place of our time and this
place where the richness and the variety
we seek in our community will become a
reality and I ask all of you today to
help make this our joint achievement now
while these and other challenges must be
addressed in the years ahead
they represent I believe both great
opportunities and cause for much
optimism about that future for each of
these challenges is dedicated to a
common goal the creation of a more
humane and a more complete intellectual
mission educational program and sense of
community at MIT late in the summer our
family moved from Winchester to take up
residence at the president's house on
Memorial Drive in a few long days and
short nights we have begun to develop a
keener appreciation of the tempo of life
on this campus we have all of us been
cheered and encouraged by the warmth of
the Welcome we have received and we are
delighted to be a part of this
extraordinary community we feel that we
belong here and we're ready to go to
work
with you
you